-It's time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags"!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Hey, we do this thing
where I send out a -- hey! --
hashtag, and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, for this week,
I asked you guys to describe
your summer --
best describe your summer
using the hashtag
"MySummerInSixWords."
For example,
I sent out a tweet that said,
"Feel the heat,
smell the breath."
Within minutes,
the hashtag became
the number-one trending topic
in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
We want to do this
every week here.
So, now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"MySummerInSixWords"
responses from you guys.
This first one here
is from @Lopey Wopey.
She says, "Didn't know noses
sweat, until now."
They do. And chins, too.
This one is from @taylorlynea.
She says,
"Trash goes out more than me."
That's smart. Keeping it safe.
This one's from
@melodybutler.
She says, "'The best summer
ever,' says my dog."
This one is
from @vansha2017.
They say, "Let's hang!
Sending you the link."
That sums up the summer.
-Yeah.
"Let's hang!
I'll send you the link."
Yeah. We're all gonna log on
at 7:00.
This one is from @CapnOMySoul.
That's kind of romantic,
Kind of?
Well, if it was "captain,"
it would probably be more.
"Capn" makes it feel
like a cereal.
-You got to say it fast
like Kirk's name -- "Capn."
"Captain of my soul"?
-No, just the "capn" part.
-Oh.
-CapnOMySoul.
-Oh, CapnOMySoul.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. But it's like Cap'n.
It's kind of spelled
like the cereal.
-Yeah, Cap'n Crunch,
Captain Kirk.
-Takes me out a little bit.
Well, it's Cap'n Kirk?
-It's Cap'n. Cap'n.
-It's not Captain?
-No.
-It's Cap'n, like the cereal.
-You look disappointed.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm bummed out.
-It's been 12 years.
-I don't call him "Captain."
Come on.
That would be weird.
Hey, Captain. I guess it is.
Anyways, CapnOMy-- Sorry.
CapnOMySoul -- he says,
"Yes, Netflix. Still watching.
Always watching."
Stop asking me.
This next one is from
@Klean Killer.
-Ooh.
He says, "Tell us about
outside again, Daddy."
This one is from
@MelissaBuntcake.
Think that's her real last name?
-Buntcake?
-Yeah. Melissa Buntcake?
-Yeah, it's probably
pronounced differently.
-Buntkik?
-Buntkake.
-Hey, hey! Hey!
-Come on, man.
-Oh, yeah. Maybe, yeah.
I didn't see the
line over the "E." Alright.
She says, "Melissa,
can you mute your mic?"
That's pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @catmomto8.
She says, "Didn't we already
watch this episode?"
I know, but watch --
It's "Ozark."
Come on, man.
Every episode is good.
Have you seen that, by the way?
"Ozark"?
-Yes.
-Yep.
-I'm only on Episode 3.
-Of the most recent season
or period?
-No. Season 1.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-You're going to have fun.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I love it.
I love every second of it.
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-And everyone's, like,
a good character.
Everyone's -- Oh.
-Bateman's the man, you know?
-He's crushin' it,
Jason Bateman.
-Yep.
-Yeah, man.
This last one is from
@SeaWolf510.
He says, "Can someone please
yell 'Jumanji' already?"
Yeah, perfect.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.